is this what sabotage looks like
churning water caused by gas leaking
from massive pipes in the Baltic Sea the
EU NATO and Russia are among a growing
number saying damage to the nordstream
system was likely deliberately caused
the focus now is on proving who's
responsible indications
foreign
three leaks have been reported in the
Russian Pipeline after scientists
detected explosions and when looking for
culprits military experts believe this
is likely a state-sponsored attack you
would need divers with special equipment
to handle these steps you would maybe
need submarines mini submarines that
could work underwater but if you have
these things and Most states do because
it's a part of Mine countermeasures
Warfare so Most states would have these
things if you have that then it's not
that hard actually
for many Russia is a prime suspect since
the war in Ukraine is slashed gas
deliveries to Europe today it dismissed
claims it attacked its own pipeline
foreign
but many European leaders are skeptical
today Denmark's defense minister met the
NATO Chief to discuss the threat I'm
told the experts from around the world
are helping with the investigations
taking place off the coast here but
answers to what happened and why could
take weeks and all the while the tension
is rising
truth be told we may never prove who's
behind this but the damage has been done
doubt and suspicion are spreading
Siobhan Robbins Sky News Copenhagen